une lampe magique à méchant une
princesse un génie
vous pensez connaître cette histoire
attend d'eux ne l'ont pas reçus une
histoire wee aa pas intéressant m'en
fous trop long bienvenue à bagdad
messieurs dames
du sultan québec n'est pas la tâche en
sorte d'en milan ont lu un mari riche
très riche et beau non bon on s'en fou
juste très riche complète on veut jeter
demandé de faire ça mais en fait moi je
méritais une bonne bien sûr tu la veux
c'est la touche d'alcool on n'arrive pas
à chasser les esprits ce jeune voleur et
ses cheveux noirs il était plus prisés
boucle il avait le regard hyper et moi à
chaque fois je vais dire un truc tu vas
me reprendre je sais pas mais je peux tu
as copie non plus impossible
elle ne veut par l'épousé en jeu et le
vizir au jeu soit tu as la rage sur le
de toi mot division qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est moi
bonjour moi j'écoutais aussi sur séoul
c'est juste à côté la cat encore
glissez pour déverrouiller la langue
à mon avis à la date bloquer la lampe
qui pensent qu'ils pointent code
et comme il me reste plus que deux
points pégase bien sûr